sie versüßt ihr die weil du siehst du
gar schneit dich mit backen vom alltag
gefreut
die weiter zu
ich mit weißen vom alten frau
das ist ehrlich
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt in
meiner heutigen weihnachtsausgabe gibt
es ein leckeres plätzchen rezept und
zwar gibt es heute ganz traditionell
spritzgebäck ich werde das spritzgebäck
später mit dem fleischwolf aufsatz
machen und ich würde jetzt einfach mal
sagen ich zeige euch gleich die zutaten
das rezept habe ich von meiner alten
nachbarin bekommen also das ist weg so
richtig altes traditionelles rezept und
ja wir gehen direkt dafür zutaten
ich brauche dafür 125 gramm butter 125 g
zucker 1 125 km haselnüsse und die habe
ich vorhin bereits im mac netcraft
blender kleinen gemacht also das waren
ganze haselnüsse jetzt sind sie fein
gemahlen und ich brauche 250 gramm mehl
drei viertel teelöffel backpulver und
etwas vanille extrakt zwischen african
habe ich vergessen das nächste mal holt
einfach eine die sich von alleine
schüttelt geführt dass ich darüber
machen muss und ich schütte es noch mal
hierhin so also wie ihr seht ist es auch
ein ganz einfaches rezept ich habe von
allem eigentlich immer 125 gramm und
dann doppelt so viel mehl also kann man
sich auch echt gut merken das rezept
jetzt kommt die butter einfach in tirol
schüssel und der teig das ist einfach so
das wird alles jetzt zusammen vom jüngst
das heißt ihr könnt ihr jetzt auch
natürlich mit einem handrührgerät machen
mit der küchenmaschine geht's bisschen
schneller beziehungsweise ich habe
einfach beide hände frei
jessica das ist eine all in one time
just jetzt sehr gut englisch leichtes
los als einfach alles rein
und ich finde die haselnüsse da drin in
diesem spritzgebäck machen halt den
besonderen geschmack aus also ich lief
spritzgebäck sowieso aber mit hasen
müssen ist natürlich noch mal einen tick
besser
drei titel also ein halber bloß ein
viertel sinken dürfen falls ihr euch
richtig und dann ordentlichen schluck
vanille extrakt das ist ja sehr
konzentriert und aus echter
vanilleschote und deswegen hat man auch
diesen tollen geschmack damit dabei so
und jetzt schön alles vermissen
jetzt ist der teig fertig und von der
konsistenz ist also als sie trocken aus
aber wenn man ihnen somit den händen
zusammen drückt merkt man das so schön
zusammen bleibt und den muss ich jetzt
erst mal kühl stellen so etwa für 1 bis
2 stunden
ihr könnt den aber natürlich auch über
nacht kühl stellen dann können dann
nämlich den teig schon am tag
vorzubereiten
und was ich noch erwähnen wollte falls
er auch haselnüsse benutzt solltet ihr
auf jeden fall darauf achten ganze
haselnüsse zu nehmen die sind einfach
viel aromatischer aber wenn ihr zum
beispiel in haselnuss allergie habt
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch die
haselnüsse gegen wandeln eintauschen
aber ich finde es halt immer ganz gut
wenn man ganz handeln und ganze
haselnüsse benutzt und die dann einfach
selber klein mal also ich denke dass
jetzt abstellen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder der teig ist jetzt schon
kalt und ich habe jetzt hier bereits im
fleischwolf auf die küchenmaschine
gesetzt und da vorne habe ich den
spritzgebäck vorsatz und ich denke wir
neben den stern oder für den stern genau
jetzt müsst mal müssen wir da oben den
teig einsetzen der backofen ist schon
vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober unterhitze
hier haben wir unsere backbleche und ich
geb dir du bist raus und stühlen hin
okay also am besten macht ihr das im
teamwork aber allein geht es natürlich
auch aber mit dass er mir geht es
natürlich besser
jetzt kommen da die sehr langen strenge
raus hier soll
das spritzgebäck ist jetzt fertig und
jetzt kommt in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad für ungefähr zehn minuten
kann auch sein dass er länger braucht
oder kürzer braucht je nachdem wie
offenbach denn das spritzgebäck sollte
so etwas farbe an der oberfläche
bekommen und danach lass ich's abkühlen
und dann wird noch spekuliert das
spritzgebäck ist jetzt gebacken und ihr
könnt es jetzt natürlich auch einfach so
lassen
ich möchte es gerne noch etwas
dekorieren mails twitter kuvertüre und
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier auch 100
gramm zar peter kober türe bereits klein
gehackt und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal wie war die kuvertüre temperiert
also ohne temperiergeräte ohne
küchenmaschine
und zwar habe ich jetzt zwei drittel von
den 100 gramm hier rein und ein drittel
hier und jetzt gebe ich zwei drittel
davon in eine kleine metallschüssel über
das wasserbad also wasserbad heißt ich
hab da unten in einem kleinen topf etwas
war katrin und darf nicht kochen es darf
einfach nur ein bisschen warm werden auf
mittlerer hitze
jetzt habe ich hier die zwei drittel
schokolade drin man sieht auch direkt
wie es anfing zu schmelzen
also die temperatur reicht auf jeden
fall aus und optimal ist es wenn die tat
bitter kuvertüre dann später auf etwa 31
grad kommt deswegen dass ich jetzt
erstmal die zwei drittel schokolade
komplett schmelzen
nehmen sie dann raus und wenn das
restliche drittel mit reingeht dann
haben wir gleich die perfekte temperatur
so jetzt ist die kuvertüre geschmolzen
und die schokolade hatte zur etwa so
circa 50 bis 60 grad und damit sie jetzt
wieder abgekühlt gebe ich jetzt das
restliche drittel mit rein und jetzt
früher ich so lange bis es sich
aufgelöst hat
also da reicht dann einfach die rest
werden und das temperieren sorgt einfach
dafür dass ich später einen schönen
glanz auf der kuvertüre habe und nicht
so einen hässlichen grauschleier
und jetzt kann ich das spritzgebäck
bereits mit der kurort hörer überziehen
entweder können dass ein drucken da
müsse aber darauf achten dass die stücke
nicht brechen oder ihre streich zeit mit
einem pinsel
die kuvertüre auf dem spritzgebäck jetzt
getrocknet und man sieht jetzt auch
schön diesen glanz auf der schokolade
also dass dies keine graue schleier hat
und es kommt eben daher dass wir die
kuvertüre temperiert haben und jetzt
kann ich ja eigentlich schon anrichte
der eigentlichkeit sicher verpackt denn
ja das ganze weihnachtsgebäck am
gleichen tag wird auf essen
und das spritzgebäck ist geschmacklich
wirklich sehr möge schmeckt richtig
toller haselnüssen und natürlich nach
der zar peter kuvertüre und ich finde
das auch ziemlich schnell hergestellt
vor allem wenn man einfach gleich eine
doppelte portion antaike macht ob man
wirklich ganz viel spritzgebäck in
kurzer zeit hergestellt
und ich find's wirklich total lecker und
hat eigentlich bei uns jedes jahr mit
dazu und wenn ihr das machen wollt geht
einfach auf meinem blog auf facebook de
und ich freue mich wenn das rezept nach
macht und mir ein foto sendet und schaut
euch schaut euch auf jeden fall auch
meine anderen weihnachts rezepte an
da gibt es bestimmt vom diesen oder vom
letzten jahr was was euch bestimmt
gefällt also bis zum nächsten mal